[Music]
i love cooking for mates but i never
make the mistake of doing complicated
formal food who wants to be stressed out
on the time off
however i do have a reputation to keep
up so the food has got to be good
whether it's breakfast brunch lunch or
dinner here's my ultimate food for
friends
having people over for a bit of a late
breakfast or brunch at the weekend is a
brilliant way to catch up with friends
and this dish is always a winner
gorgeous griddle polenta with roasty
tomatoes and a creamy ghost curd
can't wait to dive in
next a lunch to knock the socks off your
mates sensational salt baked sea bream
with easy braised leeks
and my middle daughter holly gets her
hands dirty in the kitchen as we cook a
super simple dinner
guaranteed to be a hit with all your
loved ones stunning roast chicken
stuffed with aromatic chickpeas
a beautiful big green salad and an
amazing chocolate and hazelnut meringue
tower
really good nice to see holly get our
hands there do you like i think we all
agree
this is my ultimate food for friends
breakfast lunch and dinner
first a sophisticated late breakfast or
brunch dish to impress your mates easy
griddle polenta with delicious roasty
tomatoes and creamy goats curd
now polenta to the italians is what
mashed potato is to britain's a staple
incredibly delicious and really
straightforward to do now season the
water
just a little touch of olive oil stops
it from becoming too sticky
i love polenta it's a cool meal made
from ground dried maize
the more coarse the longer it takes to
cook but you can also buy instant
polenta which is ready in under 10
minutes and always use this at home
and then whisk that out
as it cooks out
it naturally thickens
you see the grains becoming almost into
one nice fine pureed
polenta
to take the polenta to another level
flavor-wise seasoned with salt and
pepper a good knob of butter and
parmesan
quite generous with the parmesan because
polenta can be quite dull i like it
quite rich and creamy
delicious
now
mix that in
a nice smooth shiny glossy planter you
can eat polenta two ways like this it's
a glorious fluffy mash or set then
griddled which is what i'm doing
start by oiling a baking tray pour in
your polenta
now get that in the fridge and let it
set
next i'm roasting fine tomatoes to
really intensify their flavor
olive oil in the bottom of the tray
and drizzle extra virgin olive oil on
top
nip
your tomatoes with your scissors if you
didn't burst them before they went in
the oven they'll explode salt
and pepper garlic
just squeeze the juice out the garlic so
as the tomatoes blister and roast it's
going to take on all this lovely garlic
to give the tomatoes a wonderful sweet
and sour flavor a pinch of sugar and
balsamic vinegar
this is a wonderful aged balsamic
vinegar and then
some time
don't pick the time
just trim it like you're having a little
haircut
nice
the tomatoes only take 10 minutes to
roast
now the plant is set it's ready to
griddle
it should just fall out
beautiful plant is a nice garnish for
grilled meats it's great when you're
planning a big dinner party the polenta
can be done one or two days before a
nice season
top and bottom
a nice sort of coating of olive oil and
then onto your grill
now
this looks very impressive but it's so
easy to do
get that grill really nice and hot make
sure you've got a fish slice and go
underneath
to turn
all that nice sort of marking
and char in the blender gives that
really nice flavor
now tomatoes
look
you've got these beautiful vine tomatoes
that have been roasted and all that
wonderful flavor
[Music]
now
get your little tomatoes and just sit
them on top
drizzle over any remaining roasting
juices
the perfect addition is a goat's curd
goat's curd gives it that nice sort of
salty
creamy
taste goat's cheese cream cheese or
creme fraiche will work just as well
drizzle
a little touch
of that aged barcelona vinegar and then
a little basil
i can't wait to dive in
this dish is fantastic when you're
entertaining in the morning set your
plenty the night before and you can have
this casual brunch on the table within
minutes fuss-free cooking that looks
like a labor of love
[Music]
coming up i've got some great lunch and
dinner recipes when you're cooking for a
crowd
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
impress your friends
[Music]
to keep your guests sweet here's some of
the most common sugars and what they're
best for
almost sticky muscovado sugar rich and
trickly in flavour is great in biscuits
fruit cakes and pickles
powdery icing sugar dissolves without
heat making it perfect for butter creams
and icing
palm sugar made from the palm tree sap
is generally sold as a paste and brings
camry flavors to sweet and savory dishes
the secret to the meringue i'm serving
my mates for dinner is caster sugar part
way between granulated and icing sugar
in size it dissolves well it's the
ultimate sugar for baking
the main course i'm using corn fed
chicken you can buy them everywhere
they're great value they have a lovely
color and a rich flavor and with an
incredible stuffing roast chicken's
guaranteed to be a crown pleaser
and i think the kilt head variety with
his disco diva gold flash is the most
flavoursome
to check it's fresh its eyes should be
bright gills red and scales shiny
spring's great poached grilled or pan
fried but i'm going to bake it in a salt
crust for my ultimate lunch for friends
when i'm cooking lunch for a crowd of my
friends my policy is to keep it simple
and think big so instead of making lots
of little things i usually cook a whole
fish or a large joint of delicious meat
that way there's always plenty to go
around now you can have this prepared
and in the oven before any of your
guests arrive it looks super impressive
especially when you bring it to the
table this is my ultimate lunch for
friends
salt crusted sea bean served with
braised leeks and hazelnuts
first job is that salt crust this dish
looks intimidating but it is actually
very straightforward and very easy make
sure the guts are out and the fish is
clean the most important thing is always
leaving the skin and the scales on that
skin protects the actual flesh from
becoming salty give the fish a really
nice seasoning
inside even though we're putting a salt
crust on the outside it's still very
important
to season the middle fennel seeds
goes brilliantly well with fish
and then slice the lemon nice
large
thick slices the zest
and the lemon bakes inside the fish
fold over the fish and just squeeze
the juice
now for the salt
about 150 ml to 200 ml of water
what you're trying to do now is just
bring the salt
together
and you want to sort of end up with a
bowl of salt that looks almost like snow
you'll need about two kilos of salt for
this and it doesn't need to be the fancy
stuff even though you're using a lot of
it it won't make the fish salty instead
the crust forms a kiln that retains
moisture
basically
a nice bed of salt underneath
flatten it down
lay the fish on top of the salt
get your salt
and just start packing you can salt
crust almost any fish from sea bass to
salmon or flat fish like seoul but it's
not great with oily fish
now it looks like a ridiculous amount of
salt but it's really important to cover
all the fish
because you want that nice shell and the
minute salt hits the oven it sort of
tightens up and forms this
large
crust that goes in at 180 degrees for 25
to 30 minutes
whilst the fish cooks it's onto my
beautiful braised leeks
splash of olive oil
leek is a very sort of firm robust
vegetable so it can take a really nice
sear
the most exciting thing about these
leagues are they go beautifully with the
sea breeze but braised leeks colored
properly with a lot of flavor on there
tastes absolutely delicious
take a couple of cloves of garlic and
just crush them in with the leeks some
fresh thyme
get some butter in there
raising them in butter and white wine
gives them the most amazing flavor
braising is a chefy term for searing at
a high temperature then cooking with a
bit of liquid
bring that up to the boil
and then
the rest of your butter
now
as the white wine reduces down the
flavor the leeks intensifying they glaze
turn it down
just leave that little gap there if we
totally
covered it then you're gonna get all
that condensation from underneath the
lid and it'll just make the leeks watery
the leeks will take about 12 minutes to
cook so now for the garnish
roasted hazelnuts let me roast in the
oven very bristle very firm so get them
inside pestle and water for the
seasoning and just crush your nuts
don't over pound them i just want those
nice sort of rustic chopped toasted
hazelnuts now
get your knife you want that going
through with ease and turn off the gas
right absolutely adore them
like stunning little parcels
soft and slightly creamy
now baste the leeks with the remaining
butter
spread your flat leaf parsley over
generously
and then just sprinkle
the toasted hazelnuts
the combination of that earthiness from
the leeks the roasted flavour from the
hazelnuts that is a stunning way of
eating leaks
and now for the fish
and look
now just gently
tap
top
and it starts
falling away you can just see
that beautiful
shine carefully lift off
your soul
now
peel that skin
look how juicy and succulent that
seaweed is
stays incredibly moist
the other great thing about cooking
whole fish like this it makes it so easy
to fill it
take your spoon
run that down
through the top
and the fish will just slide off
there
now
just
push back that lovely fillet and look
that
is cooked beautifully
that's what keeps them coming back for
more
and more and more when you have friends
over you want to keep lunch relaxed
laid-back but impressive
and a salt crust brain with beautiful
braised leeks is just that
one of the things i've learned about
running successful restaurants over the
past 20 odd years is it's not just the
food that keeps people coming back you
need to create a great atmosphere too
and it's the same at home
my ultimate dinner for friends is
utterly delicious but it keeps things
simple and easy in the kitchen
[Music]
and helping me in the kitchen proving
this dinner's child's play to make
his middle daughter holly
first job get the chicken stuffed and
roasting
now
we all know
you love chicken
i do
but we're gonna do it's a way that daddy
used to eat it in paris okay
now i'm gonna hold that up okay season
inside please why is it yellow
because it's a cornfield chicken
obviously it's corn and if you eat lots
of corn turn yellow turn yellow
now what are those
chickpeas chickpeas yeah a little taste
nice yeah we're gonna make them taste
even better
salt pepper in there as well please now
chilies
when you hear that noise
is that me
the seeds have come out try take off the
tops
we're going to add the chilis to the
chickpeas in
and then
zest the lemon in there please you love
your zest i love my zest you're
absolutely right a little glug
of olive oil
come on holes don't worry about your
nails now
come on baby you can do it
now time you peed off all those
wonderful little butts
see
so
as we stuff the chicken with the fresh
thyme
the chickpeas become sort of fat and
juicy from all that wonderful flavor
chickpea stuffing done next we're going
to make the herb butter to flavor the
skin now what's that
tarragon
slightly vinegary yeah yeah a little bit
anna cd yep so imagine that flavour
going into the chicken
that's gonna be delicious now nice soft
butter in with a tarragon
is that lovely yeah now i want you
gently
to put your fingers through there
and just so we get that butter under
there but i need those small beautiful
little hands ew
what's wrong it's yucky come on holes
nice well done i want you
to get a nice handful of butter
lift your hand up and push under good
now see that there yeah you push it all
the way down there and you let that
slide and that's how you get all that
wonderful
yeah
butter running down and the breasts stay
nice
and moist and like you
yeah
all those chickpeas in there nice
your hands have never been so dirty have
they no here we go
good and push down
come on okay now place my lemon in there
all right
take your garlic
shall i wash my hands no
not yet
we lay the garlic
onto the tray
now
onto the garlic
salt
pepper
that keeps skin nice and crispy
and then i'm just gonna drizzle some
olive oil that will stop the butter from
burning
and look at that
please open the door thank you for that
there she goes
beautiful good job
thank you really good
nice to see holly get her hands down you
right i think we all agree
for dessert it's an incredible but easy
hazelnut meringue tower guaranteed to
wow your mates
start with the basic meringue separate
four egg whites
[Music]
and whisk
gradually add caster sugar
[Music]
until the mix forms stiff glossy peaks
gently fold in ground and chopped
hazelnuts
[Music]
a trick we use in the restaurants is to
use the mix to stick baking sheets down
which makes them easy to spread and
stops the sheets blowing around
[Music]
top meringues with more finely chopped
hazelnuts
and bake for 25 minutes
and the trick to stop them cracking is
to turn the oven off and let them cool
inside
for the filling melt dark chocolate in a
bowl over simmering water
and slightly cool
whip the cream until it forms soft peaks
and gently fold in three quarters of the
melted chocolate until combined
build your towel with alternate layers
of chocolate cream and meringue
[Music]
finally drizzle over the remaining
melted chocolate to decorate
a simple yet luxurious dessert your
friends will love but be warned they'll
all want second helpings
[Music]
the chicken's in the oven and the
desserts sorted now for a big easy green
salad
so
let's start off with one nice tablespoon
a nice little squeeze of honey
love honey good a little splash
oh aged
balsamic and this is your favorite this
one isn't it
i just like the it has a nice sweetness
but then it has a betterness to it too
nice
next to virgin novel why do we have to
use a whisk not just a spoon
the purpose of using a whisk
is so it can emulsify and more
importantly you're bringing all the
ingredients together taste
it's so yummy that is delicious
isn't it
a good tip to loosen any vinaigrette and
give it a lighter taste is add a spot of
water
now the juice
of a lemon squeeze the lemon in
nice
now use some butter lettuce
start placing the salad
around the outside this one is a lello
rosso
okay
so we'll put that one on the inside
we're making a nice flower and you put
your heart in there oh
it's just like a flower that's exactly
what i'm trying to do a nice
beautiful flower
now
from there
you crisscross your avocado what does
crisscrossing do instead of just sliding
down i'll show you now you put your
spoon in there and look
that's so cool
all these nice little bits i want you to
sprinkle those little bits in here i'm
telling you that first dinner you cook
for your boyfriend is going to be
extraordinary
that romantic dinner
the roast chicken the beautiful salad
okay yeah to the way your father taught
you
and how nice will that be all three of
us sat down and eating at the same time
very
nice are you gonna do that with megan
all of you
all of you and i'd grab the chicken
okay
now
look
at this beauty
that looks amazing doesn't it right so a
little bit
of salad whatever
you want to drizzle it
drip drip drip nice what i'm gonna do
now is squeeze
all that garlic
down see how soft
and beautiful it is it smells amazing
the lemon that we stuffed
inside the chicken roasted
what we do now is just squeeze all that
through
that nice
garlic puree
i'll tip all my
chickpeas
in there from there
some of your vinegar
in
now you crush them
and because they're still nice and hot
they absorb all that wonderful garlic
and lemon puree
the rich
delicious creamy vinaigrette
the chillies
i can guarantee you young lady that they
are the best
the finest the most delicious chickpeas
you've ever tasted
[Music]
go on then it's
yummy right
in
now little drizzle
extra virgin olive oil over them
beautifully done
[Music]
on
chickpeas
and that is a roast chicken fit for a
kingdom
this looks really yummy
let me pass the salad out please and
i'll carve the chicken
whole roast chicken stuffed with
chickpeas so with a big green salad it's
always a winner with your buddies
workmates or family chickpeas are
really really great
stuff is amazing i love chickpeas
because they're like peas from chicks
[Music]
monohulls your first chicken recipe for
you and your boyfriend
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
you